well nothing says christmas like a movie
involving nightmares capitalist greed
and carnies connie's yes it's guillermo
del toro's latest feature and at least
this one doesn't involve having sex with
a fish nightmare alley is a neo-noir
based on the 1946 novel of the same name
by william lindsey gresham and in this
video we'll be taking a look at its
ending its deeper meaning and proving
once and for all that bradley cooper can
play more than just a raccoon
and for those of you who aren't familiar
with some of my videos on films just
released in theaters i can only use
footage from the trailers and tv spots
so bear with me nightmare alley begins
rather cryptically with our protagonist
stanton carlisle dragging a dead body
across the floor of this rural farmstead
the nightmares of nightmare alley stem
from this event throughout the film
we'll get more and more clues as to what
actually transpired here eventually
culminating in the revelation that
stanton killed his own father an
alcoholic who he blamed for his mother's
abandonment he takes with him two
important items i want you to remember a
wristwatch which is father coveted and
an old radio he could probably sell for
cash with nowhere to go stanton joins a
nearby traveling circus eventually
befriending a psychic xena the seer and
an alcoholic mentalist named pete here
he learns the ropes of their psychic
scam and hones his own skills of
showmanship but stanton has dreams
bigger than that of the big top he wants
to be his own showman entertaining the
elite in high society he learns that
pete has a secret book which contains
all the secrets to his tricks including
acts that he and xena deem morally
reprehensible they call this a spook
show in which a mark is conned into
believing a loved one is speaking to
them from beyond the grave but as we'll
see with stanton he has no moral line
all he cares about is money status and
prestige and he'll go to extreme lengths
to make anyone believe what they want to
believe especially if there's heaps of
cash involved he ends up poisoning pete
and gets away with it with others
believing this alcoholic just drank too
much this allows stanton to swipe his
book of tricks but on a more
subconscious level he's taking out
another drunk a drunk who harmed a woman
he loved xena tells stanton that pete
breaks her heart he's drinking too much
thus she suffers like stanton's mother
who also experienced firsthand the harm
of an alcoholic lover for this reason
stanton doesn't drink it's a point of
pride for him but by the end of the film
he'll become a full-blown alcoholic one
night the carnival's geek escapes back
in the 40s when this story takes place
carnival geek shows consisted of a
circular ring where a performer would
bite the head off of a live chicken and
swallow it these were mainly alcoholics
or drug addicts paid in liquor and
narcotics stanton ends up finding this
geek in the carnival's aptly named house
of damnation a house with mirrors that
are captioned take a look at yourself
sinner all of this foreshadows stanton's
continual descent into damnation himself
he ends up beating the geek close to
death which becomes hauntingly ironic
since that's who he'll become at the end
of the film a damned alcoholic beast of
a man who has to resort to biting the
heads off chickens to survive is he man
or beast at the same time stanton is
brought under the wing of ringmaster
clem clem tells him how he drugs drunks
in order to turn them into subservient
geeks the two of them will later have to
drop off their geek at a local hospital
where you can see the jesus saves neon
sign and i can't help but think that it
looks rather like save us but maybe
that's just me we also see his
collection of pickled fetuses of both
the human and animal variety a
particular note is this one which clem
states as a child whose head was so
large the mother died during birth
notice the protruding eye near the top
which conjures images of stanton's
blindfold while performing in the big
city during his time at the carnival
stanton falls in love with a carney
named molly her stage name is elektra
and she performs a routine where
currents of electricity pass through her
body to win her over he designs a new
routine where they'd fake her death
using an electrocution chair of his
design and they say chivalry is dead as
the two perfect the routine we see just
how good stanton is at reading others
when a local police officer threatens to
shut down the entire show stanton is
able to talk the sheriff into letting
them continue when he uses his excellent
powers of deduction to cold read that
the sheriff's mother had passed and that
she is talking to him from beyond we can
really see that stanton's character is a
liar and a damned good one at that so
when he leaves the carnival and promises
molly the world if she comes along with
him it doesn't take too long to realize
he's lying to her too two years pass and
stanton and molly have their own show in
the big city stanton has finally got
what he's wanted but for him it'll never
be enough he wants to take his show to
the next level and this involves doing
what xena and pete warned him never to
do he'll trick some of the city's
richest citizens into believing their
loved ones are talking to them from
beyond the grave in order to amass even
more wealth of course molly is against
this but like every warning stanton
receives he ignores this leads him to dr
lilith ritter a psychologist who attends
many of his shows believing he's a con
man the two eventually team up in a
rather ingenious plot dr ritter happens
to be a therapist to some of the richest
and most influential men in the city and
through her recorded sessions she has a
ton of personal information that stanton
can exploit for example he finds out
that mrs kimball the wife of a prominent
judge yearns to know more about the
death of their son who died in the
trenches during world war 1. knowing
this stanton tells her that her son
loves her that his death was quick and
that one day they'll be reunited but
things get dangerous when stanton is
asked to do a session with unhinged
businessman ezra grindel he's wanting to
be put in touch with a long lost love
and has been burned in the past by other
con men hence why he has stan connected
to a polygraph stanton beats the
polygraph and gains ezra's trust and you
might be asking herself how did he do it
how did he beat the polygraph the simple
answer is that stanton actually believes
in his own lies that's how far down the
rabbit hole he's gone earlier in the
film there's a scene between stanton and
pete in which pete uses the term shuddai
referring to when a man has lied so much
that he ends up believing his own lies
and when those lies end you see the face
of god and no one can outrun god but
stanton is full of hubris when zena
gives him a bad tarot reading he simply
turns one of the cards right side up
this is symbolized through the hangman
card which when facing upward represents
wisdom but upside down selfishness
pretty fitting for our main character
ezra wants something stanton has never
done before to make the dead materialize
before his very eyes and stanton always
dreaming of bigger ways to con those
around him creates a plan to have molly
dress up as ezra's long-lost love a
woman who died during a botched abortion
one which ezra made her get later in the
film he confides in stanton that he had
been violent to many women in the past
but claims this woman was the one he
truly loved dr lilith says she'll take
no part in this plan she has a great
line where she says if his foot slips
both of them fall even she sees that
he's in too deep but stanton creates a
fake key to later break in and steal dr
lillis information about ezra he will do
anything to get what he wants before the
big con stanton takes a glass of alcohol
from dr lilith and chugs it symbolic of
him changing into the man he so long
hated he used to wretch at the smell of
alcohol but now he's downing a glass in
one go meanwhile molly has found
stanton's sketchbook and inside is a
drawing of lilith she believes him to be
cheating on him and it's true stanton
kisses dr lilith but it's never
explained whether this is because he
truly has feelings for her or whether
it's all part of his plan to get what he
wants but knowing his character i think
it's pretty obvious when stanton later
confronts molly who leaves him to go
back to the carnival he catches up to
her and lies telling her that he never
cheated on her and this will be their
last con you'll notice in this bus
station scene molly is the only one
wearing a colorful jacket it's crimson
red foreshadowing the violence to come
stanton's able to convince her to take
part in this final con and it begins at
stanton's command ezra prays and when he
opens his eyes in the distance is molly
dressed up as ezra's dead lover covered
in fake blood but the plan backfires
when ezra rushes over to her and notices
it's all fake i guess stanton didn't
foresee this and isn't the big genius he
makes himself out to be this reveal
enrages ezra who punches molly which
then causes stanton to beat him to death
ezra's bodyguard chases after them but
is run over by stan's car to make
matters worse remember mrs kimball the
judge's wife she's killed her husband
and herself in a murder-suicide so that
they could be with their dead son just
like stanton told her she'd be with them
when they passed everything stanton has
done has only led to death and
destruction with molly leaving for good
and the cops on his tail stanton needs
to escape so he goes to dr lilith's to
retrieve the money he stored in her safe
money he wanted to keep hidden from his
wife there he finds out he's the one
who's been conned all along dr lilith
has taken his money and set him up
incriminating him for her own safety
after a failed attempt on her life
stanton runs to the train yard nearly
escaping captivity and hides in a
carriage filled with chickens the same
animal that was killed so violently by
the geek at the beginning of the film
like the chicken his life has been
metaphorically killed sometime passes as
the next we see stanton he's gone full
hobo rocking a long haggard beard he
even sells his father's coveted watch
for a bottle of booze the film really
comes full circle however when stanton
attempts to get a job at another
carnival there he sees the radio he took
from his father those years ago and
alongside it is the one-eyed baby jar
clem had in the background the carny
boss offers him a drink just like clem
would offer a roofy drink to drunks when
he knew he could take advantage of them
he's offered the job of the geek and
when he's asked if he can handle it he
says i was born for it a little
different than what is said in the 1947
film adaptation mister
i was made for it born for it seems to
suggest it was predestined made for it
that he was crafted so i leave it up to
you why del toro went with this subtle
word change fun fact the 47 version has
a scene after this where molly comes in
and saves stanton from his fate because
the studio believed without it audiences
would think this story too dark del toro
went on to tell the la times that the
ending is quote the revelation of who
stanton really was or the way he really
saw himself that's why you'll see mere
symbolism throughout the film according
to del toro the ending is shot in such a
way that you could actually show the
final scene first and flash back to all
the events that led him there in this
way the movie is like a circle i hope
you enjoyed my analysis of nightmare
alley these videos are super tough to do
when you don't have the full footage so
i hope you were able to bear with me
thanks for watching and if you did like
the video be sure to like and subscribe
you can also follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt and remember
daddy loves you very much
you